il est temps à présent de passer à notre
chronique du jeudi pas de sport ce soir
c'est william qui nous rejoint pour une
chronique santé aujourd'hui vous allez
nous parler de prévention oui bonsoir
florane car ce matin à paris c'était le
lancement de la nouvelle application tup
l'application mobile lancée par msd
france en partenariat avec hf prévention
qui permet de localiser les points de
vente de moyens de contraception donc
tubes pour trouver un préservatif près
de chez soi grâce à son smartphone alors
comment ça marche c'est très simple on
se géolocalise à la une carte apparaît
et on voit les différents points de
vente que ce soit un magasin un point
presse ou encore les petits
distributeurs que l'on trouve à
l'extérieur des pharmacies en tout c'est
plus de 52000 points de vente de
distribution qui sont répertoriés dans
toute la france tu une application donc
très utile qui malgré son support n'est
pas destiné qu'aux jeunes se rendre
compte qu'on a pas de préservatif au
dernier moment ça peut arriver à tout le
monde
d'ailleurs les jeunes on est quand même
allé leur poser la question est ce que
ça leur est déjà arrivé et comment ils
ont fait non non pas du tout mais non ça
va pas arriver alors ça m'est arrivé une
fois et j'ai la chance d'habiter pas
loin d'une pharmacie en journée mais il
y avait une petite borne à l'extérieur
éventuellement pour en acheter dans la
nuit aussi donc j'ai de la chance
d'avoir ça à côté de chez moi je suis en
train d'essayer de me rappeler mes choix
que ça m'ait jamais vraiment arrivé
ouais voilà quelqu'un de frais voyant
mais sinon comment j'ai fait je pense
que j'ai pas fait c'est simplement je me
souviens qu'une fois je cherchais des
préservatifs et je voulais des trouver
des distributeurs mais y en avait pas et
du coup je l'entends machine mais voilà
plus de deux heures du matin non ça par
contre ce genre de situation ça m'est
jamais arrivé non la pilule du lendemain
ça m'est déjà arrivé au cas où non sans
préservatif faire sans plusieurs motifs
ensuite parce que voilà ça n'a pas l'air
d'être la meilleure solution c'est
bernard répond ça alors non c'est
certain ça ne l'est pas et la pilule du
lendemain pour éviter des infections
sexuellement transmissibles a
malheureusement toujours pas été inventé
ça prouve qu'il ya toujours besoin de
faire de la prévention
en ce qui concerne le port du
préservatif c'est donc l'association hf
prévention qui s'occupe de l'application
cube qui en est déjà à plus de cent
mille téléchargements mobiles à chaque
prévention qui je le rappelle est déjà
très présente sur le secteur de la lutte
en fin de la lutte contre les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles excusez moi
on se rappelle évidemment virus soir à
paris en octobre dernier vers histoire
c'est un jeu interactif géant qui se
présentait sous la forme d'un laser game
les participants enfilé soul enfiler une
tenue et devait à l'aide de leur
pistolet détruire le virus du sida
le jeu était resté durant cinq jours
place de la bastille et ça avait été un
réel succès changed games est le nom du
concept de ce type de jeu grandeur
nature qui avait importé des états unis
et c'était donc une grande première en
france je peux dire c'est ça de se
mettre à la page
exactement et c'est justement ça
l'objectif de l'application tube toucher
le plus grand nombre de personnes avec
des nouvelles technologies parce que tu
ben c'est pas seulement un moyen de
localiser les points de vente de
préservatifs tue c'est aussi un moyen de
trouver les centres de dépistage prix de
chez vous mais aussi d'obtenir des
informations sur les différentes ist
écoutez plutôt germandrée le directeur
de hf prévention qui vous en parlera mur
mois la version 2 est basé beaucoup plus
sur la santé sexuelle donc des gens à
l'image des nouveaux centres de
dépistage qui propose plein de
consultation sur la santé sexuelle
tu peux effectivement référence est la
seule source de référencement de toutes
ces innovations en prévention santé
on peut trouver des préservatifs qu'il
soit gratuit au payant on peut retrouver
des plannings familiaux
on peut trouver des centres de
planification notamment dans les
yvelines
on peut connaître les horaires on peut
effectivement avoir les centres de
dépistage
bref c'est la boîte à outils de la santé
sexuelle mais est-ce qu'un outil comme
celui ci est vraiment nécessaire
aujourd'hui on parle déjà beaucoup de
prévention notamment concernant le virus
du sida
oui on en parle mais c'est vrai ça ne
suffit pas aujourd'hui l'incidence de
l'infection par le vih n'augmente pas
mais ne faiblit pas non plus c'est dû à
plusieurs facteurs notamment le fait que
le virus ne fait plus peur maintenant
les gens savent que l'on peut continuer
à vivre normalement en étant
séropositive si l'on suit un traitement
il ya aussi le regard que l'on porte sur
la maladie dans les années 80 il y avait
de la compassion pour les gens qui
étaient atteints du virus du sida
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup plus de honte
et un sentiment de gêne par rapport à ce
virus pardon excusez moi il faut le
rappeler c'est un des objectifs de
l'application que des solutions de
gestion de risque et de risque sexuel
existe et atténuer ou font disparaître
le risque d'infection au virus si elles
sont adoptées attend ici l'application
tube offre un moyen d'accès rapide et
anonyme aux informations relatives à ces
solutions
une dernière étude montre que 48 % des
jeunes de 18 à 25 ans n'ont jamais avoue
n'avoir jamais effectuée avec un
dépistage au vih
il faut aussi casser les idées reçues
car 53% des contaminations sont dus à
des rapports hétérosexuels
on parle aussi des applications de
rencontres qui ont favorisé la
propagation des ist en zone urbaine le
fait aujourd'hui que les jeunes
utilisent des applications mobiles pour
se géolocaliser et pour avoir
effectivement des rencontres un peu
facile un peu rapide
ils ne vont pas forcément avoir le
réflexe de la prévention ces
applications sont pas faites pour ça
c'est des applications qui vont
permettre à des gens de pouvoir trouver
donc d'autres personnes pour faire des
rencontres
il était important d'avoir une
application qui l a été le pendant de sa
équivalait pouvoir donc présenté de la
publicité sur ses premières applications
pour les diriger vers tubes pour trouver
des préservatifs et des lieux de
dépistage
ça permet effectivement d'être présent
sur des nouveaux mai
bien sûr des médias qui sont dans les
poches des média connecté c'est pour ça
qu'on a une page facebook
c'est pour ça qu'on a un compte twitter
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui la
cible des gens qui sont les plus
contaminés c les moins de 25 ans mais
c'est aussi les plus de 45 ans alors
voilà une application qui se destine à
tous hommes et femmes parce que
lorsqu'on parle points de vente de
préservatifs on parle points de vente de
préservatifs masculins comme féminins
tube c'est aussi des fiches sur les
différentes ist et les moyens de
contraception mais aussi sur les vaccins
avec un agenda des événements liés au
dépistage et à la prévention comme les
opérations sortez couverts et une minute
pour savoir mais aussi localiser le cube
trucks le camion itinérant de la chef
prévention qui promeut l'application en
faisant le tour des villes d'île de
france en ce moment pour distincts pour
distribuer conseil et préservatifs et
bien j'espère que vous ne préviendrai
williams lorsqu'elle passera à 50 ans
qui viennent un oui et n'hésitez pas à y
aller chercher préservatifs et surtout
d'en porter parce que n'oubliez pas ce à
cause de ça qu'on apprenne perdu freddie
mercury mais aussi qu'on a eus vu naître
beaucoup d'autres artistes qu'on aurait
pu éviter